دخلت الهده الانسانيه في السودان حيز
التنفيذ مساء الثلاثاء بعد اعلان الجيش
والدعم السريع الموافقه عليها لمده 24
ساعه وقد رصد مراسل الجزيره تحريقا
للطائرات الحربيه في سماء الخرطوم ورد
المضادات عليها وعيد بدايه الهدنه التي تم
التوصل اليها بعد اتصال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي لقائد الجيش والدعم السريع
ومطالبتهما بهدنه انسانيه
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم كان خبر حلقتنا ولنا في قرشه
ثلاثه مسارات
ما طبيعه الدور الذي تلعبه القوى
الاقليميه والدوليه في الازمه السودانيه
وكيف
وعلاقه اطراف الصراع السوداني بالقوى
الخارجيه
وما فرص نجاح مساعي البناء على قبول طرفين
نزاع بالهدنه المؤقته وتطويرها الى حل
تفوضي بينهما ينهي المواجهات العسكريه
[موسيقى]
لم تكد الهدنه الانسانيه بين الجيش والدعم
السريع في السودان تطوي ساعتها الاولى حتى
تبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بخرقها في انتظار
ما ستسفر عنه الساعات المتبقيه من عمر
الهدنه عن مدى التزامهما بتطبيقها الهدنه
التي اعلن الجيش والدعم السريع التزامهما
بها لمده 24 ساعه جاءت استجابه من الطرفين
لنداءات محليه واقليميه ودوليه ابرزها
اتصال وزير الخارجيه الامريكي بقائدي
الجيش والدعم السريع وطلبه منهما وقفا
لاطلاق النار لاسباب الانسانيه وبينما
يحبس السودانيون انفاسهم لمعرفه مصير
الهدنه اعربت قوى سياسيه سودانيه عن املها
في نجاحها بل وتشكيلها اساسا لمفاوضات
لانهاء المواجهات بين طرفي نزاع
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من
الخرطوم السيده الرشيد المعتصم الباحث في
مركز الخرطوم للحوار و السيد حافظ كبير
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن واشنطن
الدكتور كاميرون المبعوث الخاص السابق
للرئيس اوباما الى السودان ومسؤول شؤون
افريقيا السابق في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي مرحبا بكم جميعا سيد رشيد
المعتصم ما السياقات التي دفعت الجيش
والدعم السريع للقبول وبهذه الهدنه رغم
تشكيك الطرف
بالطرف الاخر ورغم الخروقات التي سجلت حتى
الان
مساء الخير شكرا جزيلا فيما
دعم السريع ابتداء انا ارى ان
القواعد المقاتله في الارض تتابعه للدعم
السريع ليس لها صله الان مع قياده الدعم
السريع
فهي مجموعات متناثره لا تقودها رطب رفيعه
وهي لا تدري ماذا يدور في عالم السياسه
اصلا يعني هي منقطعه عن قيادتها لذلك
الاساسير البيانات التي تصدر يعني يعني عن
قياده الدعم السريع هي بيانات في الاسافير
ما عندها علاقه
اعتبارا
شرابط العلامه السريع الارض هذه القوات
تبحث عن المياه والشرب والاكل وتعتدي على
المحلات حتى لانه عندها من مخزون
فهي تبحث عن
يعني عن الاكل والشرب وتعالج به موقفها
الحالي هي يعني تعمل
غلط عضوي ولا معلومات عن ما يجري يتعلق
بالجيش السوداني ما الذي دفعه للقبور بهذه
الغدنه رغم تشكيكه بنوايا الدعم السريع
السيد حافظ كبير
وضحت سيد حافظ كبير الجيش قال بان موافقه
الدعم السريع على هدنه لمده 24 ساعه هي
للتغطيه على ما سماها طبعا الجيش هزيمه
سيتلقاها الدعم السريع في الساعات المقبله
ما اهداف الدعم السريع من القبول في هذه
الهدنه لمده 24 ساعه
المشاهدين انا اعتقد ان الحديث هذا والله
المتحدثون الذين يؤيدون مثلا رؤيه الجيش
يكرمه منذ اليوم الاول بان هذه القوه قوه
غير منظمه وانها منقطعه عن قيادتها وانها
تائهه او هائمه على وجهها في الخرطوم وهذا
الحديث لا تكذبه حقائق موضوعيه الان
موجوده هناك يعني استمرار للمعارك
والاشتباكات لفتره يعني اربعه ايام مستمره
هذا لا يمكن ان يصدر من من مجموعات متقطعه
الشيء الاخر واضح ان لدي هدف يعني ولديها
تنظيم ولديها اتصال بقواعدها ولديها طواصل
مع المجتمع الدولي مثل ما حدث امس يعني ما
قعدت سريع مع مع
القيد
الدعم الدولي او لا يريد
يعني تنجح الحكومه في تصنيفره متمرده
وبالتالي غير ملتزم بقواعد الاشتباك ولا
يعني الاعراف اعراف الحرب ولا كذلك
بحقوق الانسان وما الى ذلك وبالتالي
الامكان وبالفعل وافق على الهدنه الذي خلق
الهدنه هو ان الطيران سلاح الجو حلق يعني
مع بدايه بدايه دخول الهدنه وهذا يعني هذا
ايضا كما قال ضيفك الكريم ربما ينطبق
انطلق على الجيش باعتبار ان الذين يعني
وافقوا على الهدنه واعلنوا ذلك الجيش لكن
الذي خلق الهدنه ربما نقول انه لا يسيطر
على قواته وهي التي خلقت الهدنه وبالتالي
او
باعتبار اعتبارات التي ذكرها ضيفك الكريم
ينبغي ان يلتزم اكثر من غيره ينبغي ان
يلتزم بالهدنه باعتباره مؤسسه عريقه يعني
يعرف اهميه هذه الجدامات وياتي بالتزاماته
امام المجتمع الدولي امام من الشعب
السوداني
طبعا
قائد الدعم السريع السيد حميتي قال بانه
وافق على الهدنه بعد اتصال مع وزير خارجيه
الامريكي انطوني بلينكن على ماذا تعول
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه من هذه الهدنه
بين الطرفين نساء في السودان
الطرفين
للالتزام بالهدنه لان كلا منهما مسؤول عن
العنف الميداني الرساله من واشنطن مافادها
انه لا يهم من بدا
يكمن في عدم اعطاء المصداقيه ومشروعيه
مبالغه بها
لطرفين لانهما يحبسان الشعب ويدمران الشاب
يجب ان يفهم انه كيف مكان الحل لا يمكنهما
ان يلعب دورا مستقبليا في السودان سيد
معتصم اشار قبل قليل السيد حافظ كبير بان
الخروقات التي حصلت حتى الهدنه يبدو لان
الجيش السوداني لا يريد تنفيذ هذه الهدنه
بحسب قوله هل الجيش معني فعليا بالالتزام
بهذه الهدنه لمده 24 ساعه
المواطنين يعلمونه ويراقبونه ويرسلونه عبر
السوشيال ميديا معلومات كامله موثقه لحركه
قوات الدعم السريع في كل ارجاء السودان
المتوفر من المعلومات الان ليس للعسكريين
للقوات المسلحه السوداني
ان هناك تحسين لقوات متحركه الان في اتجاه
من غرب من ناحيه الغرب يعني تتجمع من
ناحيه دارفور ودخلت كردفار تحرك نحو
الخرطوم وهناك حركه لقواتهم من الناحيه
مروي ودخلت والان القوات في الملتقى ثم تم
معالجه التحييد بعضها ولكن بعض هذه مجموعه
من العسكريين المصريين فالتعامل معها
هذه المجموعه معروف لكل السودانيه انها
موجوده في منطقه الملتقى
ان يعني ان عن عن مؤن
يعني اعتدوا على المحلات التجاريه واخذوا
المؤن يعني الماء والاكل والشرب وهكذا
الدع
وه الثانيه لاغ
رار هي يعني في الاعلام وفي العلاقات
الخارجيه تسمح له بالاستمرار وفي غرفه جيش
السوداني ان هذه المعركه هي
يعني معركه وجود الدوله المركزيه نفسها
يعني
فمن العسير جدا ان ان يكون الجيش
موجود لانه ليس فصيلا سياسيا لكنها قوات
عسكريه متمرده الان في غرفه الجيش فهذا
الامر بمكان من الحساسيه الجيش نفسه لا
يمكن ان يرقوا لهذه يعني لانه هذا الوضع
يعرفه لمح
اسبه
جمهور عسكريه متمرده هذه ليست فصيل سياسي
اذا اذا نفهم منك انه لن يلتزم بالهدنه
سيد المعتصم نفمنك بان الجيش لن يلتزم
بالهدنه
قواعد الدعم السريعه موجوده اصلا في
الخرطوم لم تاتي من الخارج موجوده بجوار
القياده العامه في حي المطار يوم القرب
بهذا الامن في حول النطاق في الرياض في
شارع الستين هي اصلا موجوده في بيوت سكنيه
وفي مغاره عسكريه جيش نجح في تحيه كافه
المواقع العسكريه المعروفه اللي فيها
الزخائيل وفيها القوات وفي
كل الذي بقي هذه القوات في الاحياء صحيح
ما بعض الزخاير والمؤن والاليات لكن
التعامل معها يعرض المواطئ يعرض الخصائص
ستكون كبيره
180 قتيلا حتى الان بحسب المبعوث الامم
يسمح لي انتقل للسيد حافظ حافظ كبير
الدعم السريع الان يقاتل في في اماكن
مدنيه كيف سيتصرف اذا هذه الهدنه ولاحقا
ايضا في ظل هذا الانتشار الواسع في مناطق
في الخرطوم مقتظه بالسكان
يعني هو القتال
يعني كما نعلم جميعا ظروف القتال يعني كل
طرف يقول بانها لكن
المواصفات العسكريه داخل اشكال قديم
القياده العامه وكذلك عدد من المقام على
الجيش وكذلك التي تتبع لهيئه العمليات
سابقا التي
الاصل في اماكن المواطنين
اقول ان هناك اشكال اخلاقي
في هذه الحرب باعتبارها يعني ابتدى داخل
المدن في اماكن اهله بالمواطنين ووجود هذه
المؤسسات العسكريه داخل المدن لم لم يؤسسه
الدعم السريع بل استه المؤسسه العسكريه هي
التي يعني ظلت موجوده في هذه الاماكن منذ
مده طويله بالرغم من المطالبات الكثيره
بان تكون
المدن خاليه من المنشات العسكريه نحن
تابعنا ان هناك ايضا مصانع للزخائر وتصنيع
الحربي موجوده بداخل داخل المدن حتى عندما
قصفت الطائرات الاسرائيليه في عهد النظام
البعيد قصفت هذا المصنع كان هناك ضررا
كبيرا وذعر في يعني لدى المواطنين بالتالي
الاشتباك الذي يحدث في مثل هذه الظروف
الكباب داخل المدن
كل يلقي بالله مع الاخر يعني وبالتالي
هناك طبعا حق الدفاع
وبالتالي اذا كان هناك اراده اذا كان هناك
مسؤوليه يجب الالتزام ليخفي اطلاق النار
التزام بالهدنه وتطويرها في اطلاق
المواطنين نحن ايذاء موقف معقد للغايه
لحتى قبل
هذه المؤسسه واحده انشقت عن نفسها
الذي تقول
الصوت متقطع كثيرا ساعود اليك سيد حافظ
سيد كمال هاتسون ما فرص نجاح المساعي
الخارجيه ليس فقط في الالتزام التزام
الاطراف بهذه الهدنه بل لتثبيتها ربما
وصولا الى وقف اطلاق النار واطلاق طاوله
مفاوضات بين الطرفين
انه يجب ان نكون مشككين في الموضوع يجب ان
نقيم
وقفه اطلاق النار كل ساعه بساعتها لنرى ان
كانت طرفان جديين ما اخشاه هو ان طرفين قد
يتوقفان لبرهه من اجل سماحه للفرقه
الدبلوماسيه
وفرق الدوليه ان تغادر المدينه ولا تقف في
مرمى النار واتساءل ما سيحصل حين ذاك لم
يكن هناك مراقبون لهذا العنف اذا ترك
المدنيون في المدينه
لوحدهم راينا ان طرفين ليس مهتمين لحياه
المدنيين ولا للبنات تحت المدنيه انا فعلا
اخشى لو انا اعضاء الاسره الدوليه قد
غادروا الرساله التي نحاول ان نبعث بها من
العواصم الدوليه من اجل ضبط النفس سوف
تكون اقل تاثيرا لانه لن يعود لدينا اي
فرق دبلوماسيه موجوده انا اعرف ان سفارات
الاجنبيه في الخرطوم بدات تدرس خياراتها
من اجل ان المدينه وتخرج طواقمها منها
طبعا هناك خطر كبير عليهم كما ان الخطر
كبير على المدنيين السودانيين ولكنها
رساله سيئه من الاسره الدوليه اذا ارادت
ان تسحب طواقيمها وتترك السودانيين
لوحدهم في مدينه تعيش حربا بين فصيلين
متقاتلين لا اعرف كيف استدوا النتيجه يجب
ان نكون حذرين يجب ان نلقي الضغط ونمارس
الضغطه يجب ان نذكر طرفين باستمرار
بطبيعات تصرفاتهما ربما المساءله
والمحاسبه لن تاتي غدا ولكن يجب ان يدرك
انه سيتم محاكمتهما والحكم عليهما على
اساس خياراتهما ويجب ان نوثقه وبنشاط كافه
الجرائم التي نشهدها الان من اجل ان نحضر
للمستقبل ويجب على الطرفين ان يدرك ذلك
اذا سيد رشيد المعتصم هكذا يرى الغرب الان
طرفي الصراع بالسودان بانهما غير مهتمين
بحياه
المدنيين
كيف كيف ينظر الجيش السوداني لهذه المواقف
الغربيه تجاه هذا الصراع مع الدعم السريع
الغرب نفسه تاريخه في العمل السياسي
الخارجي في المعارك العسكريه في اوكرانيا
الان المجتمع الدولي نفسه منقسم
ويحارب بعضه البعض يعني المجتمع الدولي
نفسه في حاله حرب غير اخلاقيه ايضا
كثير كلفته خسائر اقتصاديه وجرائم
الانسانيه كبيره سلاسل القزاع ماسي كبيره
جدا جدا دوله الدوله التي يتحدث باسمها
السيد قمر الذي يتحدث عن قضايا السودان هي
دوله
جيران في تاريخ الانسانيه منذ تاريخها
القديم ما فيش دوله ارتكبت جرائم والحضاره
قديمه في التاريخ مثل الجرائم التي
ارتكبتها الولايات
ما ذكرته الان هل يبرر تجاهل الحفاظ على
حياه المدنيين في هذا الصراع بين قائدين
عسكريين
اقصد ذلك انا لكن يجب عليهم ان يحترموا حق
الجيش السوداني وحق الدوله السودانيه في
محافظه مكافحه
فكيف فكيف لمفكرين
ومتحدثين باسم مراكز دراسات يتحدثون عن
يعني المقارنه بين جيد بين دوله تحاول ان
تحافظ على استقرار الدوله المركزيه مع
فصائل المتمرده
المساواه بين الصفا المتورده ودوله
والدوله مركزيه هذا امر غريب ايضا لانه
تاريخ السودان نفسه عانى كثيرا من كاميرا
ودولته الحصار الذي طردته الامر الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي احد اسباب الحرب
التاريخيه في السودان لان الحصار الامريكي
تسبب كثير من الخسائر السودانيين تسبب في
في انهيارات لمؤسسات كبيره مؤسسات
البنيه التحتيه حرم السودان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه حرمت السودان هي التي
اصغرت السودان وهي احد اسباب الحروب
السودان الحديثه القديمه والحديث
فالولايات المتحده هي تاريخيا ينظر اليها
باعتبار ان
احد اسباب فصل جنوب السودان على كل حال
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه وما حصل في
السابق ليس موضوعنا الان السيد حافظ كبير
الجيش اشار قبل موافقته على الهدنه لمده
24 ساعه استغرب من ما قال بانه الحديث عن
الهدنه واشار الى حشد الدعم السريع لقوته
خاصه في مروي لاستقبال ما يقول بانها
طائره مساعدات عسكريه تاتي من جهه اقليميه
هل الدعم السريع معني بانخراط
باجندات خارجيه في السودان
[ضحك]
مع الاسف الصوت الصوت غير صالح سنحاول ان
ان نصلح هذا الخلل لانه نريد ان نسمع
وجهه نظرك السيد حافظ كبير في الخرطوم سيد
كيف تنظرون الى الدور الاقليمي في هذا
الصراع ما بين السيدين حميدتي والبرهان في
السودان
انه قتال حتى الموت حتى خط النهايه
وهذا امر كان يتحضر منذ سنين بين الاثنين
وانا دائما كنت اشكك في قدرتهما على
الجلوس الى طاوله مفاوضات ليقرراه فيما
بينهما كيف يصلحان المؤسسات دعونا لا ننسى
في الاسابيع الاخيره لم نسمع اي اصوات
مدنيه في النقاش حول اصلاح القطاع الامني
وارى ان هذا عيب او خطا كبير في هذه
العمليه من الدول الثلاثه بدعم من الدول
الخارجيه هذا خطا وعيب قاتل لانه سمح
للجنرال البرهان والجنرال الحميتي ان يكون
في موقف حيث ان المفاوضات والتنازلات
والتسويات صارت متعذره وهدم ادى الى
القطاع الذي نشهده اليوم
لبى الاهم من ذلك
وعلى ما اراه هو ان ايا منهما ليس جديا
بالنسبه الى تسليم السلطه الى المدنيين كل
منهما جدي في حمايه قوتي وتاثيره ومصالحه
الخاصه
[موسيقى]
كلهم منهما يصرح بانه سوف يمشي قدما في
المسار السياسي
ولكنهما كان يحاولان شراء الوقت يؤخراني
ما لا يريدان حصوله من اجل صياغه
استراتيجيهما كل على حده لقد اختار كل
منهما المسار الذي يناسبه الذي يعرفه اكثر
من غيرها الا وهو مسار الحرب وبالتالي لا
يجب ان نتفاجئ اطلاقا ان نجد انفسنا في
هذا الوضع وان القوات الامن سوف لن تتمكن
من اصلاح نفسها والطريقه الوحيده لمنظومه
الامنيه لكي
تصلح نفسها من خلال الحرب طبعا هذا فشل
اعيده او اعتقد انه السبب فيه هو الاسره
الدوليه وكذلك الاطراف الداخليه
اليك ساعيد طرح السؤال انطلاقا من اتهام
الجيش للدعم السريع بانه يحشد قواته
استعدادا لاستقبال مساعدات عسكريه من جهات
اقليميه للدعم السريع معني بالانقراض في
اجندات خارجيه في هذه المرحله في السودان
واذا ما كان لديك رد عما قاله السيد
كاميرون بان الطرفين غير معنيين حاليا
بالتوصل الى اتفاق في الداخل السوداني
يعني الذي اريد ان اقوله ان هناك من
الخارج وعداء لاي دور دولي من قبل
المجموعات التي تؤيد المكون العسكري وهذا
العذاب قديم يعني متعلق باجنده النظام
السابق وعناصره الموجوده ما تزال موجوده
وترى في اي دور خارجي يريد بانه تدخل سالب
وبالتالي مثل ما ذكر ضيفك ان الاسره عندما
تتدخل وتقوم بدورها
ينظر الى هذا الامر له انحياز او انه
التدخل يعني انتهاء السياده وهذا غير صحيح
بالطبع يعني كذلك يعني الحركه التي يتحدث
عنها البعض بانك دعم السريع ينقل الجيوش
هذه الجيوش متحركه منذ فتره طويله والدول
والجيش نفسه وذكر بانه دمر المعسكرات وترك
هذه القوات المتحركه وبالتالي حركته هذه
الطبيعيه في اطار انها يعني غير متمركزه
بالاساس في مكان الواحد بالنسبه هذا ايضا
يقودنا الى تنبيه ضيفك من واشنطن
بان الذي لديه مصلحه في اعداء الولايات هي
ليس الدعم السريع وانما هناك مجموعات يعني
معروفه بعدائها للولايات المتحده ولا اظن
ولا اعتقد ان الدعم السريع سيضع في هذا
الخطا في هذه المرحله بالاعتداء على بعصاد
دبلوماسيه وهو الذي يتفق معها في العمليه
السياسيه ويؤيدها بشده ويؤيد القوى
المدنيه التي تعمل الان من اجل استعاده
المسار الديمقراطي
في هذا السياق اذا سمحت لي اين القوى
المدنيه وما مصير العمليه السياسيه
انطلاقا مما يحدث الان على الارض وهذا
الاقتتال بين قائلين عسكريين
اجتمعت الولايات المدنيه بتسهيل من الاليه
الثلاثيه واكد على عدد من النقاط من ضمنها
على وقف الحرب والدخولات في حوار اعتقد ان
القوه المدنيه او اتفق معسون بانها بانه
هناك ضعف في القوه المدني وانها لم تستطيع
ان تفرض الظروف المدني والعسكري ولكنها
تركت هذا
للاطراف المتصارعه الجيش يريد الانفراد
بالمؤسسه الامنيه والعسكريه وان يحوز على
كل مفاصلها وان يعيد اصلاحها بنفسه دون
تدخل مدني وهذا امر اتفق مع نضيفك الذي
قال بان الاجهزه الامنيه لا تستطيع اصلاح
نفسها لابد من وجود اشراف مدني على
العمليه عمليه عمليه الاصلاح الامني
والعسكري وبالتالي هناك يعني دعا يقالها
قائد الدعم السريع بانه بعد الخلاف الكبير
الذي نشر بينه وبين قائد الجيش بانه لا
يريد ممارسه السياسه وانه يدعو الى
التسليم السلطه المدنية دعنا نختبر هذه
المعقول التي قالها فلنمضي قدما في تسليم
السلطه المدنيين حالا ونبعد الجنرالات من
السياسه ونبعدهم من التدخل في قرارات
المدنيه
واذا الذي يجني بالبلاد هذه الصراع
المدمره حديثك عن ان ليست دعم السريع هو
من يعادي الولايات المتحده الامريكيه صيد
صيد حافظ المعتصم كيف فهمتم رساله قائد
الدعم السريع السيد احمدتي عن انه يواجه
الان من وصفه بالاسلام الراديكالي باشاره
منه الى رئيس مجلس السياده السيد البرهان
المؤسسات الراديكاليه هو السيد حميد متى
بدا في عهد الرئيس عمر البشير اراده
الراديكاليين الذين يتحدث عنهم هو ربيبهم
وهو ابنهم الشرعي فهو ايضا جزء من برنامج
المجموعات
موجوده في السودان هو يجوز منها اصلا وهو
احد يعني صنيعتها يعني هو يحاول ان يحسن
صورته الخارجيه لان السيد حميتي يعني
يمارس السياسه بشكل براجماتي يعني يتمحور
حول نفسه ويبني في ثرواته الخاصه وهي ليس
الثروات لمؤسسه لكن لاشخاص واسمه الاخوين
دقلو فالسيد دجله واخوه
فكيف
على الاقل المؤسسه العسكريه هي مؤسسه
قديمه ولها تراتيب غازتها يسحب ون معروفه
وفترات
لكن كيف لاشخاص يحتكرون قوه عسكريه
ويسيطرون على اموال
وكيف لهذا الامر يعني واي صوره هذه التي
يمكن تحسينها يعني وكيف سيديرون امره
التنوير واسع وفي شكرا لك اريد ان اخته مع
السيد كاميرا بدقيقه واحده لو سمحت ما
مالات هذا الصراع بين الطرفين وهل يمكن
للغرب ان يبني على هذه الهدنه وان كان
هناك خروقات حتى الساعه ان يبني عليها
للمتوصل الى طاوله مفاوضات بين الطرفين
بدقيقه واحده لو سمحت
رايي الشخصي هو ان ما سنشهده وان قوه
الدعم السريع ستسيطر على عدد من المناطق
حيث هي ايضا مسيطره
والجيش سيسيطر على المناطق المدنيه حيث هو
اصلا يسيطر ومن ثم سيضطرني الى الجلوس الى
دوله مفاوضات من اجل التوصل الى التسليه
نهائيه لكن خوفي هو انهما خلال ذلك
سيدمران البلاد ستزهق الارواح
وهذا فعلا يجب ان نتفادها شكرا السيد
كاملا هاتسون في واشنطن السيد حافظ كبير
والسيده رشيد المعتصم في الخرطوم شكرا لكم
جميعا اذا مشاهدينا الكرام طبعا هذه نهايه
ما وراء الخبر ولكن التغطيه مستمره لاخر
التطورات في السودان الى اللقاء بامان
الله ورعايته
[موسيقى]